nothing well them now we got zoom
you need to see how unfulfilling that is
for some people right it's like
there's nobody watching what do i do i
need that accolade
do you think those are still worth it
the zoom shows absolutely
yeah because they teach you another
level they teach you to relate to this
thing right there
right and it's like you this is that's
unusual
but how does that impact you now if you
get an agent you start doing commercials
and now you have no problem talking to
the camera like i'm talking to you guys
right
i'm looking in your eyes right but it's
so weird because in comedy
we don't look in everybody's eyes at the
exact same time
so it's a little different but you can
you can actually use it and ponder and
do that sort of thing
you can use your your framing to go you
know it's like uh you know it's like and
i can't do this and
you know it's like i can't do anything
because i'm jewish i can't
you know i can't uh i can't watch
stranger things on the sabbath i can't
do this
and it's like i can't covet my
neighbor's wife and she's hot
you know always coming over what another
cup of sugar
so you can do that and use the frame
to create the joke so if you're
imagining what's what's
what they're seeing in the frame you
could utilize that to your advantage
and they force you to be more creative
now so
but you see how that you're seeing it in
a different perspective too
now they could see your eyes now you
could do facials now you can do things
with your eyebrows that maybe you didn't
do before
right you know used to do a true and
false quiz in class you know
my friend and i would send signals he'd
he'd study one night i'd study it the
next night would split the work
in half next day he'd be looking at the
at the question he'd go
all right that was true he'd send the
signals that one's false
he has no idea you know so now you have
now you could do that where they
wouldn't be able to see you up on the
stage in the back from the back of the
room so
there's those advantages also watch john
john oliver watch how he when he first
started after the pandemic
doing the shows sort of remotely and how
it evolved
and he's just like wow he doesn't even
stop for the laugh
it's just it happens by accident
and it's so riveting that's why he won
another emmy
you know because that's something to
to take from if you see so if you join
these gyms
zoom shows see what other people are
doing steal the moves that
are working if the oh that guy gave a
look like that that seemed to really get
a lap oh i can use facial expresso
i can do a deadpan i go you know and she
wants me to come over
get him to use that camera to your uh to
your affected
shift a dynamic level in your act you
know
it's like you know and this is all going
on of course
during the pandemic you know or
during the apocalypse you know that
gives it a conspiratorial
type of thing you know use that camera
as you're leaning in and trying to
whisper to them
if you're serious about becoming a
comedian join our facebook group linked
in the description below to start
getting tips like these every single day
and watch this playlist of our top
writing tips to improve your writing
[Music]
today